welcome back everybody
I'm outside the Bel Air home where
Hollywood socialite and actress jaja
Gabor passed away this weekend
she and her now when were Prince
Frederick von Anhalt lived here for
their entire 30-year relationship he
provided care for Gabor during the later
parts of her life and sometimes that
meant shielding Zsa Zsa from reality we
keep everything positive she doesn't
know when she lost her leg she found out
a year and a half later because I didn't
tell her that she saw it all of a sudden
you know I don't tell her bad news I'm a
positive guy that's not the only thing
Frederick didn't tell jaja
the Prince also kept her daughter's 2015
death a secret from her all in the name
of protecting his wife my life it's all
about jazz why kappa i don't call we
were with josh i 1986 when she said i do
for the ninth time marrying von Anhalt
at her Bel Air home she became his
seventh wife these are the nicest take
longer Stella's I'm in love me till they
make a hundred years old I give a man
and he doesn't leave it in a Christmas
tree his title has been called into
question with some reports claiming he
wasn't born into a royal family in 2007
he was found naked and tied to the
steering wheel of his Rolls Royce the
victim of an alleged robbery never had a
gun on my foot so that's the first time
I had something like that earlier that
same year he made headlines when he
claimed to have had a decade-long affair
with the late Anna Nicole Smith and took
a DNA test to determine if he was the
father of her daughter Dannielynn
naturally if it is positive then it's my
baby and I shouldn't leave my baby alone
I should fight fern and I will bring her
home
the test was negative and today looking
back the now widowed Prince has no
regrets access to care for my life that
was my duty as a husband